[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry
its magical student population and how
exactly students are selected for the
school
now hogwarts has a rich history and
dates back to the 10th century
it's located in the scottish highlands
though we don't know exactly where
and its location is largely hidden
because it was built during a time
when witches and wizards were still
being persecuted by muggles for their
use of magic
hogwarts was founded by four witches and
wizards who all had
the self-same yearning to make the
world's best magic school
these founders were godric gryffindor
rowena ravenclaw
salazar slitherin and helga hufflepuff
and when they finally got together
hogwarts was born hogwarts has a great
reputation
and over the course of the centuries
that it has existed
copious amounts of talented witch and
wizard alumni have emerged from its
walls
it's the finest school of witchcraft and
wizardry in the world
according to hagrid so the school has
been around for a
very long time it seems like every year
the school boasts
just as many students as the previous
year but
just how many students actually attend
the school how many students receive a
top-notch
magical education each year in an
interview in october 2000
rowling was asked how many students
attend hogwarts and
how many students are there in each
house rolling replied with a very to the
point
there are about a thousand students at
hogwarts and while that would give us a
nice sum to work with
250 students per house and fortunately i
don't think that this figure makes much
sense
in both the books and films there is
nothing that appears to indicate such a
large number of students
and this number heavily conflicts with
the world that we've been introduced to
hogwarts students attend the school for
seven years which means that
based on the figure of a thousand
students total there would be
approximately 36 new students from each
house
per year if there are an equal number of
boys and girls
that would mean that 144 students 72
boys and 72 girls
started hogwarts each and every year a
more widely recognized figure
or at least a more widely fan
appreciated figure
is that there are 280 students at the
school total
that's 70 students from each house and
10 new students per house
per year this seems to make a lot more
sense but
my next question is how are the walls of
hogwarts filled
year after year how are these students
chosen to attend the famous wizarding
school
how do they find out that they have been
chosen first of all i want to point out
a clear distinction between muggle-born
students and students that come from
magical families the families of
students who come from a magical
background
are most likely already privy to
hogwarts and it's highly likely that the
parents of the student
attended the school themselves however
the families of muggleborns
would have no concept of magic at all
i.e hermione
and that is why there are different
procedures for different types of
students
all young witches and wizards should
expect a hogwarts acceptance letter
the hogwarts acceptance letter informs
new students of their acceptance to
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
and along with the letter includes a
list of required textbooks
and materials required for the upcoming
school year when a which wizard from
magical family receives this letter
things are fairly straightforward they
know the procedure and when the time
comes for them to go to school
they're brought to platform nine and
three quarters and sent off
the procedure for muggleborns however is
a little bit different
as i'm sure you can imagine the shock
and surprise the surge of confusion
when receiving a letter like that from
hermione
nobody in my family's magic at all it
was ever such a surprise when i got my
letter
but i was ever so pleased of course i
mean it's the very best school of
witchcraft there is
i've heard i've learned all of our
course books by heart of course
i just hope it will be enough i'm
hermione grange by the way who are you
and also colleen creevy it's amazing
here isn't it
i never knew all the odd stuff i could
do as magic till i got the letter from
hogwarts
my dad's a milkman he couldn't believe
it either so i'm taking loads of
pictures to send home to him
and it'd be really good if i had one of
you he looked imploringly at harry
maybe your friend could take it and i
could stand next to you and then
could you sign it in the case of muggle
warns hogwarts dispatcher is a member of
staff to travel to the home of said
muggleborn student
so that the letter can be properly
introduced and explained
the books don't actually acknowledge
which staff member is directly
responsible for this
however as mcgonagall is in charge of
the registrar
it makes most sense that would be her
responsibility i can't even begin to
imagine how difficult it would be to
explain
magic to a muggle a real monster of a
task
however if it's going to be anyone i
think that either dumbledore or
mcgonagall would be most convincing
in the films we see dumbledore
travelling to wall's orphanage to inform
tom riddle of his acceptance to the
school
though he was magical he had no parents
that he knew of so it was necessary for
a member of staff to come and explain
the process
as well as a magical world okay so
that's how students are
informed of their acceptance but how are
they actually
accepted how are they specifically
chosen for hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry enter the
quill of acceptance
in a small ox tower never visited by any
student at hogwarts since an ancient
book that has not been touched by human
hands
since the four founders placed it there
on completion of the castle
beside the book which is bound in
peeling black dragon hide
stands a small silver ink pot and from
this protrudes a long
faded quill these are the quill of
acceptance and the book of admittance
and they constitute the only process by
which students are selected for hogwarts
school
of witchcraft and wizardry the book and
quill were put in place by the founders
of hogwarts
to aid with and automate the hogwarts
selection process
they knew that for centuries they would
need students to be selected for the
school
and there's no way that they would be
able to manage it manually one of the
main parameters put in place for
detecting students
is as follows at the precise moment that
a child first exhibits signs of magic
the quill which is believed to have been
taken from an augury floats up out of
its inkpot and attempts to inscribe the
name of that child
upon the pages of the book this means
that as soon as a child
shows any form of magic it is
immediately set in writing
that they are a magical being no child
would be able to perform magic
undetected without this magical book and
quill taking note of it
how the book and quill actually operate
is anyone's guess
if anybody understands what powerful and
long-lasting magic causes this book and
quill to behave as they do
nobody has ever confessed to it
doubtless because as albus dumbledore
once said
it saves the staff tedious explanations
to parents who are furious that their
children have not been selected for
hogwarts
the book and quill's decision is final
and no child has ever been admitted
whose name has not
first been inscribed on the books
yellowing pages one thing that is worth
mentioning
however is that sometimes the book and
the quill don't quite agree on what
constitutes
magical activity a mere whiff of magic
suffices for the quill the book
however will often snap shut refusing to
be written upon until it receives
sufficiently dramatic evidence of
magical ability
in the case of neville longbottom for
instance the quill was eager to write
his name in the book
right at his birth he came from magical
family and exhibited faint signs of
magic right away
but no one seemed to really notice the
book included it has been reported that
it was not
until he was eight years old did either
his disappointed great aunts and uncles
or the old sickler of a book except that
he was truly a wizard
when he survived a fool that should have
killed him for centuries the book and
quill have selected students for
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry
and for centuries the quill's
sensitivity coupled with the book's
implacability
have never yet made a mistake and that's
it for this video
did you guys know about all of these
steps which surprised you
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard harry
[Music]
you